salut alors si vous avez cliqué sur
cette vidéo dans l'espoir de voir une
démonstration super convaincante du
manque de scientificité de la sociologie
ou plus simplement une liste des défauts
que l'on pourrait reprocher à cette
discipline
vous êtes sans doute sujet au biais de
confirmation un des plus vicieux biais
cognitifs je commence cette vidéo ainsi
parce que certains s'en vouloir à tout
prix opposé sociologie et psychologie
on l'a encore vu récemment avec la super
vidéo de la chaîne youtube patchwork sur
les théories du complot dans les
commentaires on retrouvait cette idée
selon laquelle on peut pas s'emmerder à
considérer tout un tas de paramètres
sociaux pour éclairer une situation
qu'on estime entièrement réductible à
des paramètres psychologique est parfois
si quelqu'un avance que l'angle
psychologique manque une dimension du
problème ou qu'ils favorisent des
conclusions dangereuse on en voit qui
s'énerve sérieusement ici même à
l'occasion de la vidéo sur les pauvres
blancs de la culture j'ai eu le droit à
un commentaire assez étonnant qui
déclarait au passage que la sociaux
n'était pas une science c'est pas comme
si c'était le sujet de ma vidéo 1
et si elle met bien bourdieu en valeur
c'est aussi en opposant un finkielkraut
onfray ou enthoven et je ne prends pas
qu'on puisse dire que ces gens soient
des scientifiques
pour autant on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
me dire que la sociaux ce n'est pas une
science comme je ne suis pas du tout un
spécialiste de sociologie
ce n'est pas moi qui vais vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est chouette pour cela je
vous renvoie vers ces deux chaînes
patchwork donc déjà mentionné et
grégoire simpson peut-être que ça se
prononce en buisson may ping l'aise
en revanche ce que je peux faire moi en
ma qualité de nos experts s'est
esquissée des hypothèses comme des
invitations à creuser je vais tenter de
faire des paris comme un bon bézian un
premier truc qu'elle je pense quand je
vois la défiance pour la sociologie
c'est ce même évidemment ce même est une
illustration du réductionnisme
et vous l'avez compris je ne suis pas
super fan de la proche réductionniste
pour ce qui est de penser la société
mais en fait je montre ce même parce que
je ne comprends pas comment ceux qui
adhèrent au projet réductionniste
justifie le fait qu'ils intègrent quand
même la perspective psychologique s'il
ya bien une team psycho antisociaux que
pensent ses membres des positions
matérialiste et digne nativistes comme
celle des tshirts landes parce qu'en
gros pour ces gens là
les énoncés descriptif
en psychologie ont autant de valeur
épistémique que les propositions
sociologique hong hong pour 1 et
éthicien fanatiques dans les deux cas on
trouve ça tout pourri on a parfois envie
de répondre en étant encore plus
royaliste que le roi n'a rien de réel
mais seulement une illusion de la
conscience phénoménal donc seules valent
les énoncés de la neuroscience
pourquoi votre zèle scientifiques ne
nous conduit pas à refuser également la
psychologie et bien on pourrait nous
répondre a raison parce que ça marche et
je suis bien d'accord
la psychologie ça marche c'est à dire
qu'on accorde une valeur pragmatiste aux
énoncés de psychologie au sens où l'on
considère que cette manière là de
décrire l'esprit humain même si elle ne
peut pas prétendre être une description
véritablement fidèles de ce qui se passe
dans nos têtes
elle est intéressante au sens fort du
terme elle nous permet d'interagir
efficacement avec l'esprit ça permet
d'anticiper ou d'orienter des
comportements ça permet de soigner etc
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas au moins
reconnaître cette valeur là à la
sociologie comme même titre que la
psychologie la sociologie reçurent un
rapport efficace à la société c'est à
dire que les énoncés de la sociologie
permettent de saisir des phénomènes
sociaux d'une manière qu aucune autre
approche ne perd mais je trouverais
gonflé de ne pas reconnaître ça et je
serai donc tenté de faire un premier
pari bézian les gens qui rejettent la
sociologie n'ont jamais fait vraiment
ils ont vaguement entendu les discours
de sociologues ont eu un entretien dans
le monde mais ils ne sont pas plonger
dedans avec rigueur on pourrait dire
qu'ils ont manqué de charité épistémique
ils n'ont pas donné sa chance à la
discipline en essayant de comprendre ce
qui fait sa logique interne et en quel
sens elle permet de produire des
descriptions pertinente de la société
c'est très important pour se faire une
idée sur une discipline de comprendre
comment elle entend fonctionner quels
sont ses objectifs ses méthodes
les difficultés qu elle se reconnaît et
les puissances qu'elle fait sienne si on
ne connaît pas ça on juge avec un
horizon d'attenté sur déterminé on
s'empêche de comprendre comment
certaines personnes travaillent pour
penser notre monde on s'empêche
d'expérimenter une perspective
différente
c'est un peu dommage donc déjà voilà je
fais le pari que le fond du problème
c'est qu'on se fait une image
caricaturale de la discipline ça
pourrait suffire me direz mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là il y a plusieurs motifs
qui viennent justifier le rejet de cette
image caricaturale et j'en vois trois
principaux d'abord ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le rejet d'orgueil c'est celui
de celles et ceux qui ne veulent pas
être mis dans des cases
non je trouve pas un pot ok bon lâche
caricature en fait ça m'arrive d'être
témoin d'un tel rejet dans des versions
beaucoup plus fine j'ai des gens qui à
d'autres égards sont très pros sociaux
même ils se disent de gauche et chaque
fois qu'il tente de panser la société et
ses enjeux politiques il favorise langue
sociologie mais dès qu'il s'agit
d'analyser leur propre vie il refuse
catégoriquement
l'angle social que se passe-t-il dans
ces moments là en général on avance des
arguments psychologique pour mettre en
avant la singularité de sa personnalité
ce que j'ai le plus entendu se résume
ainsi ne pas réduire ma vie caractère
mais quand mes préférences à une
situation sociale et à la limite je ne
veux même pas répondre à cette
affirmation ici on pourrait peut-être
tentés de voir dans quelles conditions
elle peut être pertinente mais là ce qui
m'intéresse ce que je trouve éclairant
dans cette idée qui revient sans cesse
c'est le verbe réduire car cela j'ai
envie de répondre qu'une situation
sociale renvoie un nombre considérable
de facteurs différents la sociologie ne
perd pas avec des énormes catégorie
super sommaire du type les bourgeois et
les prolos au contraire il s'agit
d'affiner le plus possible et observer
une situation sociale c'est découvrir
des milliers de paramètres des milliers
d' influences diverses et variées donc
c'est absolument pas une réduction au
contraire c'est même le moyen d'ouvrir
vers de nouvelles pistes de réflexion
et pourquoi pas d'ailleurs en
psychologie en observant telle ou telle
situation sociale on découvre que
certains individus sont exposés à tel ou
tel stimuli et cela représente une base
supplémentaires pour mieux comprendre
comment les êtres humains pris isolément
ou en groupe se comporte et
interagissent tout simplement
la sociologie n'a donc rien de
réducteurs puisqu'au contraire elle
complexifie ou plutôt révèle la
complexité de l'objet d'études mais de
loin c'est pas l'image qu'elle donne et
ne nous voilons pas la face il est
agréable pour un être humain de penser
qu'il est unique différent des autres et
qu'on ne peut pas le mettre dans une
case
aussi sophistiquée soit elle surtout que
les injonctions contemporaines sont
justement celles de l'unicité
on le voit dans la publicité on le voit
à la télévision
il faut absolument être différent et ne
pas être différent c'est perdre toute
valeur sociale et on responsabilise
énormément les individus de ce point de
vue le message sous jacent c'est tout
simplement vous devez réussir même les
autres l'idéal du self made man est
diffusée à grande échelle par la culture
américaine première exportatrice de
valeur et d'idéologie donc forcément
dans un monde où on est censé se sortir
les doigts pour devenir quelqu'un on
regarde d'un mauvais oeil cette
discipline qui semble dire que notre
identité dépend étroitement de notre
environnement
deuxième forme de rejet dans la
continuité de ce qu'on vient de dire le
rejet pour des raisons explicitement ou
implicitement morale et politique cela
peut avoir au moins deux causes
distinctes
d'abord il ya les gens qui n'aiment pas
entendre parler de politique de manière
générale en fait aux risques de
schématiser on pourrait dire que ces
personnes aiment réfléchir nourrissent
une curiosité pour les avancées
scientifiques se donne pour défi de
mieux penser mais tout ça est finalement
une sorte de divertissement
j'emploie ce terme en un sens purement
descriptif à l'ats pascal c'est une
manière de passer son temps d'occuper
son esprit à des choses team u nantes et
ça nous détourne des problèmes liés à la
condition humaine
ça permet d'oublier tout ce qui met de
mauvaise humeur ça peut conduire à dire
des trucs un peu bancal comme ben oui si
on politise si on me remet sur la table
des sujets qui fâchent s'agace
l'innocence de la passion pour la
science
parce qu'on a tout simplement pas envie
de penser à ça pas envie de penser aux
gens qui souffrent d'injustice et
surtout pas envie de s'entendre dire que
notre passion n'est qu'un divertissement
les amoureux de la sociaux de ce point
de vue ce sont les rabat joie ce qui
nous répète tout le temps que le système
est défaillant et qui empêche de
profiter de la fête mais comment cette
posture est elle reçu par le camp d'en
face par les amoureux de la sociaux donc
disons qu'il est difficile de ne pas
penser que quand quelqu'un dit ouais
politisé c'est pour justifier le fait
que pendant que d'autres se penchent
activement sur les questions politiques
et morales donc des questions
douloureuses et source de prise de tête
on continue de privilégier les questions
non politique divertissante et source de
plaisir la justification se fait sur
fond de grands principes
ça ressemble à moi je sais que la
science je m'occupe de la vérité et la
science est apolitique et elle doit le
rester
donc c'est tout à fait normal que je ne
m'occupe pas de politique bien sûr
parfois ces mêmes personnes se
prononcent quand même sur des faits de
société
alors la multiplication devient parce
que je parle de la société je cherche à
la faire avec la neutralité qui
caractérise l'idéal descriptif de la
science donc il est normal que je ne
m'engage pas à défendre une cause
sous-entendu le meilleur garde possible
est toujours le regard neutre qui ne
prend parti pour rien
ce principe là est impossible à tenir
rigoureusement et j'ai déjà expliqué dix
fois pourquoi la neutralité est une
chimère
donc je ne vais pas recommencer ici
notons que la science propose un
paradoxe qui nous arrange bien sur le
plan psychologique
elle a une image noble on considère que
c'est quelque chose d'important et donc
c'est valorisé socialement mais dans le
même temps s'intéresser à la science
peut nous détourner du social
schématiquement gajan que la
valorisation sociale du travail
scientifique est légitime
les scientifiques sont importants pour
la société oui et d'ailleurs
la science a une énorme valeur politique
au sens on lui donne souvent pour
fonction d'améliorer les conditions de
vie des gens la technologie pour le
confort la médecine pour limiter la
souffrance
etc etc donc maintenant reste les
spectateurs et spectatrices les lecteurs
et lectrices de contenus scientifiques
à ma gauche les pros sociaux à ma droite
les anti sociaux
celles et ceux qui se cultive en
sociologie sont souvent conduits à
s'impliquer voir à s'engager pour
essayer de corriger ce qui apparaît
comme des défauts systématique
entraînant des injustices la culture
sociologique est une culture qui a une
fonction collective elle transforme le
rapport de l'individu au collectif à la
société comme ensemble de groupes
sociaux s'intéresser à la sociologie
c'est se tourner vers les autres de
l'autre côté celles et ceux qui se
cultive ancion durs sont conduits à je
sais pas trop en fait à rien non à part
le plaisir personnel qui via à se faire
une culture scientifique
quel autre intérêt pour et on y trouvait
en tout cas il n'y a pas de fonctions
sociales clair dans cet engouement on
dirait bien que la culture scientifique
soit avant tout un plaisir personnel
une activité tournée vers soi sauf à se
cultiver sur des sujets politiques bien
sûr comme le climat la médecine le
nucléaire mais lors du coup on en
revient à ce qu'on disait plus haut si
on s'intéresse la société on doit
prendre en compte les outils
sociologique
donc a renoncé à l'esprit la valeur
sociale qu'on donne à la culture
générale qu'elle soit artistique ou
scientifique est douteuse c'est un
élément de distinction comme on s'aime
et donc troisième et dernier projet le
rejet pour des raisons qu'on pourrait
appeler d'idéalisme scientifique
ce sont les gens qui veulent croire que
l'être humain et la société sont
réductible autant que possible aux
sciences formel même s'ils ne vont pas
jusqu'au au matérialisme élimine
activistes qu'on ait évoqué plus haut
ils sont prêts à accepter la psychologie
parce que ça ressemble davantage à une
science dure de manière générale ils
sont mal à l'aise avec la pensée qui se
nourrit du langage naturel et donc avec
la pensée qui nécessitent des
interprétations il préfère quand les
conclusions sont claires et précises
pour ne pas dire définitive ils ne sont
pas fans des concepts je veux dire des
mots qui ont une épaisseur sémantique
une inertie qui demande une oreille
une sorte de sensibilité linguistique ce
sont des gens qui ne lisent jamais de
philosophie classique par exemple il ne
s'intéresse pas à platon my girl ou à
nietzsche ils n'ont jamais vraiment
compris l'intérêt qu'il pouvait y avoir
du point de vue de la pensée à se
confronter à une langue singulière au
contraire c'est leur part les mêmes
suspects ou contre-productif une pensée
qui génère des interprétations
contradictoires
un texte qui produit des malentendus on
ne peut rien bâtir là dessus du style
c'est l'échec assuré
et honnêtement il y a des gens très
intelligents qui pensent cela et même
des philosophes ils ont leurs raisons et
il sera difficile de les convaincre du
contraire
toujours est il que je fais le pari des
liens suivants les gens qui se passionne
pour la philosophie continentale qui
sont séduits par les création
conceptuelle des postmodernes qui
éclairent leur regard sur le monde et
sur même en décortiquant des aphorismes
de nietzsche ces gens là ne sont pas
tous intégralement tomber dans l'arnaqué
intellectuelle du siècle
oui bien sûr certains se font kiffer en
déconstruisant la déconstruction des
constructeurs parfois jusqu'à produire
des textes aussi illisible que
complaisant mais ça ne suffit pas à
justifier qu'on jette le bébé avec l'eau
du bain
ces modes de pensée ont leur logique
propre et leur effectivité
et ce n'est pas un canular monté par des
gens qui n'en sont pas spécialistes qui
devrait nous faire penser le contraire
bref celles et ceux pour qui tout ça
apparaît comme de la fumisterie comme de
la masturbation intellectuelle sont
conduits à se méfier de tout ce qui
semble s'en rapprocher
les sociologues ont leur copain avec les
philosophes postmoderne alors ça les
rend encore plus suspect ça peut pas
être de la science c'est forcément de la
branlette
je suis toujours fasciné par ce désir de
condamnation définitive
comme si on ne pouvait pas dire sur la
ligne franchie
non c'est direct et la poubelle roger
bonus là manuel valls expliqué s'est
excusé je ne sais pas s'il faut
s'attarder là dessus ça demanderait de
se pencher sérieusement sur la notion de
responsabilité individuelle et sa
rallongerait la vidéo d'une bonne
trentaine de minutes
disons ceci pour le moment le sentiment
de responsabilité individuelle aussi
fort soit-il n'est soutenue par à peu
près rien d'autre que par lui-même mais
chez un humain un sentiment ça peut
suffire à guider une existence donc faut
pas s'étonner qu'on continue de vivre
comme si nous étions tous des bonhommes
libre et indépendant maintenant une fois
qu'on se rend compte que cette hypothèse
est une planche en carton mouillé on
pourrait peut-être se dire que ça
vaudrait le coup de sortir du faux
dilemme excusé culpabiliser mais
pourquoi est ce que ça fait si peur de
sortir de ce dilemme
il y a probablement une angoisse sous
jacente à l'idée de mettre le nez dans
le grand mythe de la responsabilité
individuelle et du mérite
en général il est super difficile voire
flippant de remettre en cause l'idée que
chacun est responsable de soi et donc
d'ébranler la croyance selon laquelle
les chèques de mon voisin n'a rien à
voir avec mon succès
c'est tellement reposant devant les
choses ainsi pour d'évidentes raisons
liées à la culpabilité
on n'a pas du tout du tout envie de se
dire que ce qui explique mon succès est
aussi ce qui explique l'échec de mon
voisin un système inéquitable et donc
oui la sociaux fait chier parce qu elle
nous force à prendre conscience de tout
ça elle révèle que nos privilèges ne
sont ni légitime ni méritée
il est possible que ce soit ça la pilule
la plus difficile à avaler
et je comprends c'est hyper
culpabilisant et ça nous dépossède d'un
motif de fierté donc de plaisir mais
d'ailleurs ce serait pas un biais
cognitifs sa refuse tout discours qui
met en danger l'amour propre
je taquine joaquin blague à part
à cela s'ajoute un truc encore plus
relou c'est que si la responsabilité
n'est pas individuelle elle est
collective
alors là c'est la goutte d'eau non
seulement je ne peut plus profiter de
mes privilèges l'esprit tranquille mais
en plus je suis censé me préoccuper de
ceux qui souffrent à côté de moi c'est
trop alors avant de conclure laissez-moi
apaiser le truc une seconde parce que je
sens que certains se serrent les dents
je ne veux pas juger ces anti sociaux
pourquoi parce que tout simplement s'il
est si difficile d'accepter les
conclusions de la sociologie
s'il est si vertigineux accepter qu'on
n'est pas libre donc pas responsable de
son bonheur et s'il est aussi douloureux
de se dire que le moindre plaisir qu'on
expérimente risque d'être teinté de
culpabilité s'il est si compliqué de
comprendre qu'on devrait aider les
autres davantage si les sites
désagréable de penser que notre passion
pour la science n'a rien de spécialement
noble et qu'elle n'est qu'un passe-temps
intellectuels comme un autre c'est parce
que pour ces gens là aussi la vie est
dure et compliquée et ils ont besoin
comme tout le monde de trouver des
moyens de la rendre plus douce la
sociaux permet de se pencher sur tous
les groupes pas seulement sur les
défavorisés et même les privilégiés
souffrent eux aussi ont des angoisses
les dépressions même ceux qui ont la
chance de pouvoir se divertir en passant
leur temps libre à se faire une culture
étatique souffre et devant la sociologie
ils ont l'impression qu'on les dépossède
aussi de leur souffrance qu'on y leur
douleur qu'on dévalorise leurs problèmes
qu'on les accuse d' un comportement
immoral égoïste comme si on leur disait
france elle ne vaut rien parce qu'elle
n'est pas générée par une injustice
systémique et ça c'est une violence
supplémentaire et cette violence conduit
à refuser tout discours qui implique
cette idée est donc le mécanisme de
défense consiste à discréditer
totalement le camp d'en face de tenter
de le ridiculiser et donc on fait des
canulars on les traite de charlatans ou
plus simplement on met en avant leur
militantisme afin de prouver que leur
discours ne peut pas être
scientifiquement pertinent parce qu'il
est forcément teintée d'idéologie qu'il
est radical j'aurais tendance jeu là
vous
à plaindre tous les êtres humains en
général parce que tous les êtres humains
souffrent tous les êtres humains ont
peur et tous les êtres humains ont des
raisons de penser que la vie est injuste
parce que la vie est injuste mais la
société est injuste d'une manière
particulière d'une manière qu'on peut
effectivement corrigé et pour corriger
des injustices que la société ajoute aux
injustices de la vie il faut la
comprendre et pour cela on a besoin de
tous les outils à disposition la
sociologie en est un et pas des moindres
il est terrible que monsieur x souffrent
parce que sa femme est malade mais cette
souffrance tient en grande partie à des
facteurs psychologiques sur lesquels
nous avons très peu de prise mais si
madame y
en revanche souffrent de ne pas trouver
d'emploi à cause de sa couleur de peau
ou de son genre ou de sa religion
alors nous faisons face à une souffrance
bien différente car celle ci tient en
grande partie à des facteurs politiques
sur lesquels nous avons une vraie prise
pour le dire autrement nous pouvons
transformer les règles de la société
bien plus facilement que les doigts de
l'esprit et c'est pour cette raison que
l'angle sociologique et si précieux à
tous les anti sociaux s'il vous plaît
demandez vous sincèrement et je vraiment
donner sa chance à la discipline
n'ai-je pas au fond de moi envie que la
sociaux soit de la merde n'ai-je pas le
profond désir de pouvoir discréditer ses
conclusions si oui alors il ya de bonnes
chances que votre refus soient motivés
pour de mauvaises raisons et vous êtes
forcément d'accord avec moi parce que
c'est typiquement ce que vous reprochez
au camp adverse des croyances motivée
par des sentiments
merci pour votre écoute n'hésitez pas à
si ça vous a plu à soutenir la chaîne en
vous abonnant en partageant et surtout
en commentant c'est vraiment beaucoup de
boulot et c'est vos retours qui me donne
l'énergie de continuer salut